well one of these stand-up moments for
me the Grammy Awards uh we're not the
actual Awards themselves uh but this
Madonna looking like she got the wrong
date for Halloween well now she's taken
to Instagram to say many people chose
only to talk about close-up photos of me
gospel bid that him I'll be photographed
Madonna taken with a long lens camera by
a press photographer that would distort
anyone's face once again I'm called in
the glare of ageism and misogyny that
permeates the world we live in a world
that refuses to celebrate women past the
age of 45. well they had to discuss this
podcast from comedian James Barr talked
to the contributors to Krakow associate
editor of the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire
so Kevin I woke up this morning to
Madonna because I had past comment of
the critical nature about Madonna and
she tweeted the world is threatened by
my power and my stamina my intelligence
and my will to survive but they will
never break me this is all the tests and
there was a very filtered picture of
herself which had clearly been through
the filtering minister so here's my
thing about Madonna Kevin
I think she is an absolute joke now and
I say that as somebody who was a massive
fan I literally went to see her on the
Holiday Tour one of the greatest pop
stars at her Peak I've ever seen she has
become an embarrassing shambles quite
deliberately and I when I saw these
pictures I just I once again thought my
God what did she a what she done to
herself but B the constant attention
thinking she was making horrible sexual
signs with Sam Smith they she was doing
all sorts of stuff his normal you know
the normal attention seeking and it just
does the ACT doesn't play when you're in
the mid 60s would you have been outraged
if Mick Jagger was doing that I had the
same way I mean he doesn't do what she
does yeah but it's come on she is a
victim of ageism but at the same time
she's a victim of her own she's always
out there trying to get noticed and if
you go out there and try and get noticed
you're going to get jeers as well as
cheers you're a self-confessed Madonna
super fat yes is she is she a victim of
ageism and misogynist absolutely and the
fact that we're sat here two men sat
here discussed three men discussing
misogyny is misogynistic so Kevin is
you don't get an opinion on whether
Madonna is telling her truth or not
that's her what is her truth that people
are being misogynistic and that a woman
is not allowed or permitted to be sexy
there is in the eyes of people like you
there is only there is only the truth
there's not people's versions of it
we're not on the Megan and Harry podcast
right so you can't just say her truth no
there are facts the fact is she's done
stuff to her face surgically which means
when she goes out now we all shriek in
horror I think it's quite rude to say
that you shriek in horror I literally
did and it's like a Halloween costume
but ultimately appears that you've met
Madonna you you called her rude she was
incredibly rude but I don't hold that
against her but it sounds like you do
actually just don't be wrong women are
allowed to be they're allowed to be rude
little madams and she is right no
problem at all women are allowed to not
like you people absolutely it doesn't
give you permission hack them James is
not a problem at all she can hate my
guts it doesn't mean I can't pass
comment on her without being called
immediately misogynist but is anyone
discussing how you look and all the time
okay with that literally I get fat
shamed all the time even though as you
can see I'm basically emaciated right so
so and this is the new regime by the way
it's the new year new me and it's all
just falling off so yeah um sure but I
you know why because I got a vaccine I
actually think it's good I'm Madonna
needs to listen to proper friends who
say to her what the hell you do to your
face love right look at that it's like
the bridal Wilderness it's not misogyny
to notice that she looks crazy I'm a
huge
like if she was my friend seriously I
think the issue here is she's too rich
to be looking this crazy I have no
problem with cosmetic surgery there are
loads of celebrities I've had it done
the aim is not to look crazy I'm a huge
fan of her and I just think she's too
established she's too much of an icon to
do this
to notice is that she's telling you why
perhaps in your opinion she looks the
way she looks and she's kind of victim
it's not crazy
even you don't think she's I do think a
lot of misogyny of ageism of people like
you saying she literally seeing that
she's not permitted to be sexy in her
60s
I just said that when somebody's that
desperate she releases picture after
picture of herself naked lying under
beds you know all sorts of kissing toy
boys it's all attention seeking
narcissism fine what you can't do is
look at this picture here now the idea
the idea I can't criticize that [__] is
say that is desperate for women in the
60s I mean without you you saying you're
being ages to misogynist no I'm not
James Barr look at her she's hot that's
a hot piece of that I mean that looks
like a dead cockroach
your great grandma which by the way
she's old enough to be honestly like a
it's like it looks like a crime scene
doesn't it that's what it does yeah
I don't know if your grandparents are
still alive no sadly my nan is not here
but imagine if she was and that was her
and she released that picture I would
love that really yeah I've got friends
whose grandmothers are on only fans like
get out there I'd have to have a quiet
word right well I think you'd probably
be feeling a little uncomfortable but
mainly because you might be finding it
attractive here's my point I don't think
you can behave the way Madonna behaves
and not expect criticism so then play
the victim when you deliberately provoke
people if I think you'd have said it
would be like me playing the victim when
I give it out large with my opinions and
then say and someone says to me oh stop
being so disgusting [__] oh my God I'm
a victim look I see a lot of it is
embarrassing I look at Helen Miller who
I think it must be a bit older and it's
really sexy and in a very different way
but some of the criticisms you get is
motivated because of her age and because
she's the one once because she gets more
because she Witnesses she wants to play
the 25 year old sexy and she's 64. right
and I'm sorry Esther but I would say
there's something about mate Jaguar when
he's ever done it the old you know
strolling bone thing on stage just like
come on they put it and he used to stop
having children um look I I don't think
it's a misogyny to notice when someone's
acting nuts right or looking
yeah
I think it's fine of Madonna
she is and I like that about no no
she is Madonna she's an icon she will
always be an icon this is completely
unnecessary and it's not ages of more
sexism or misogyny to notice that this
isn't necessary but by the way look look
James here's the point you've bought
tickets to a concert millions of other
people have and will it'll be a Smash
Hit she's not a victim she might be many
other things but all this does is fuel
the sort of Fury around Madonna and
she'll make even more money there's
still even more tickets but it's just
the playing the victim which got my goat
this morning he's like Madonna of all
things stick it back to me call me a
ruffle English twerk whatever you want
to call me I don't care I don't care but
don't play the victim because it's
pathetic I don't think it's pathetic
that she's just sold out a world tour of
30 plus dates in seconds I don't think
that's I think it's absolutely baffling
but if you want to go and watch her
prancing around in her 60s looking like
that enjoy your show James thank you so
much words of Madonna there's no greater
power than the power of goodbye he
indeed James goodbye
that seems slightly immaterial girl uh
anyway